sie hören sie sehen eine sammlung von
texten die längst vergessen sind eine
sammlung von momenten gegen das
verschwinden des theaters 6 neben
figuren aus verloren gegangenen stücken
die dem spielplan abhanden gekommen sind
die ausgesondert wurden für nicht
systemrelevant erklärt was ihnen geschah
geschieht dem theater nun selber es wird
geschlossen ausgesondert vergessen wir
spielen an gegen das vergessen wir
spielen an gegen das verschwinden und
lesen deshalb aus vergessenen stücken
der decken gestalten zum leben und
drehen die regler mit fremder sprache
buch gerade jetzt wo alles schlafen soll
monologe szenen debatten miniaturen
konzerte tanz wir proben wir spielen wir
denken weiter denn das theater als ort
der verwandlung des zweifels des
fremdseins das muss überleben daran
wollen wir glauben
davon wird man ja wohl noch träumen
dürfen
[Musik]
eine böse arbeiter mehr die sich nie
gegeben hat aber deren wirklichkeit
fantastisch ergreift die foto von eysel
lasker-schüler uraufgeführt 1919 das
auch weiter für seine fabrik statt in
wuppertal drei rennen an langsam
schweigend über die brücke der eine
mord- unheimlich es ist der panels
rederecht sein linkes ausgelaufenes auge
bedeckt eine schwarze klappe der zweite
es lange anna er trägt deine hand
harmonie gar an einen fischers mann band
um die schulter der dritte ist der
glessener amadeus der nimmt vorsichtig
platz auf der stufe von der brücke trägt
wird die beiden anderen setzte sich auf
das gelände der brücke der acht weiter
auf rost und seinen gespenstischen
löschen kommen dazu haben zusammen kommt
ja schon von der q5 er altert gehäuse
amadeus du blut ist ja lass uns mal
bluten auf den nasen rennen das fängt
auch angeschaut zu reden auf ein traum
durchlesen erst roppelt immer masons
lutschen seit man still
es gibt noch was hinter der düsterkeit
wahrt man wenn es erst licht wird ja was
der licht das können wir auch machen
versteckte visage in dein schatz ist
deckelchen fremde rechner wieder seinen
pinsel raushängen person zu können ich
habe angst wir wollen bei mutter gehen
dann erhebt
es ist auch zeit macht euch nach haus so
kleines bald nicht mehr auf der straße
ich sag euch lang mache ich so ein leben
nicht mehr mit wenn du friederich was
hast du von deinem leben ich hab nix ums
leben hieß er probiert zum zeitvertrag
so ein foul des zeitvertreibs für seine
freundin katzi gefühl dass eine charge
will dann holt sie mir aus seiner kiste
und von den tieren rannten bekommt man
selten die herzen fielen in dem die
buchsen
ich mache ich oft seine oper lässt du
dich nicht kriegen tun wenn es reden
lassen selber was hast du eigentlich von
der sauerei und guckst man immer so wie
das eine original kopf rein lautaro der
mutter post die hatten mittel dafür aus
dem zuchthaus kirchhof holt sie die
totenköpfe und treibt sie zu zucker in
herzlija
wenn du wartest auf mich und im zweifel
bist du wie medea dir begegnen möchte
nachdem sie deine liebe ziel erfahren
dass tiefer dein vertrauen zu mir nicht
könnte schmerzen jedoch verschwinden
kleine sorgen vor dem größten glück und
größtes glück für mich mein sohn ist
eine heirat
zwar endet an dem tag an dem ich braut
und bräutigam zum braut begleite mein
letztes recht an deine herrlichkeit
vergessen dass ich deine mutter war muss
ich danach geduldig üben und schatten
eines glücks nur ist es wenn freundlich
man mir sagt dass ich großmutter heiße
doch einem glückstag opfert man das
sorgen reiche leben gern
und das will ich seit seinem siebenten
lebensjahr ist fern du meiner pflege
schnitzt sich doch buchung schwert und
wie's und was ein knabe lieben mag doch
besser mit der männer hände
zwar wären meine hände voll dämlich
gewesen waren sie doch träge nicht den
geist des jüngeren bruders zu
befriedigen
es zog zum vater dich zu männern dich da
widerstehen ist der frauen
hoffnungsloses mühe
was ich versuchte um so spät die früchte
schmerzlicher geburt von deiner
schönheit ab zu pflügen mißlang und
zeugte widerwillen gegen mich in dir
genug genug
du warst von meinen augen fort gerückt
nicht etwa dass sofern war es durch die
jahre ich sah den edlen gang an dir und
deiner hände mannigfache taten und eines
auges augen leuchten sah was jeden
ausgestellt doch deine ganzheit sah ich
nicht dar wonach sich mütter sehen
deines leibes blühen reifen nicht was
sklaven zu vergönnt ist
badelt dich zu schauen da ich nicht dein
vater erntete das glück dass ich mir
einst erhoffte und zuflucht meiner
wünsche blieb die eine nacht in der ich
den gesetz gehorchen dir und deiner
braut die kerzenhalter dann werde ich
dich sie und was mein leib geboren
erfahren endlich warum alt und
gebrechlich schauen was mein inneres
auge bildete vergaß ich doch kein zartes
fältchen und keiner muskelspiel in
meinem herzen
es ist mit schönheit überhäufte und mit
gebärden wie bildhauer sich die götter
denken
wenn sie ihnen nackt erscheinen und
siegen wirst du über mich der übleren an
allem
demütig fertig werden und mich dem
mysterium der liebe beugen nicht länger
locken gegen meines jobs dorn verehren
lernen neidlos lieben werde das
männliche ich das über uns hinweg stammt
wie die stiere nicht zweifle daran dass
mein segen dich begleiten wird
nur eines zeigt mir dass meine augen
sehn sucht die nicht lästig sein wird
[Musik]
der neue renault sa oder geschichte des
kubanischen prinz andy von jakob michael
reinhold lenz ein text von 1774 eines
kompromisslosen modernen der
schonungslos missstände benannte deren
thematisierung zeitgenossen in diese
form vermieden
ich reise aber nicht vorwärts zurück
ich habe genug gesehen und gehört das
wird mir zum ekel nach kongo nach kuba
einmal wieder atem zu schöpfen
ich glaubte deiner welt zu sein wo ich
edlere leute antreffen als bei mir große
viel umfassende viel tätige ich ersticke
wollen sie zur ader lassen spottet ihr
nein
in der tat sich sind zu blut reich ich
glaubte im hastigen reden denen etwas
zugestoßen
in eurem morast ersticke ich treibst
nicht länger mein seel nicht dass der
aufgeklärte welt teil
allenthalben wo man hinrich lässigkeit
faule ohnmächtige begleitender tod für
für feuer und leben geschwätz für
handlungen dass der berühmte welt teil
obwohl jedoch erlauben sie sie sind noch
jung und denn sind sie ein fremder und
wissen sich viel in unsere sitten zu
schicken und zu rücken
das ist nur nichts gerät ohne vorurteil
mein freund ganz mit kaltem blut ich
fürchte mich weiter zu gehen wenn mein
missvergnügen immer so zunimmt wie
bisher
aber wisst ihr was die ursache ist das
eure sitten nur fremden so auffallen
ich mag nicht reden ich mich entsetzlich
weit ausholen
ich will euch zu fliegen lassen und nach
hause reisen in unschuld meine
väterlichen besitztümer zu genießen mein
land regieren und mauren herum ziel dass
jeder der aus europa kommt erst
quarantäne erhält er seine pestbeule
unter meinem untertan vervielfältigt
also das ist erstaunen allerliebste
prinz ich wünschte gerne dass sie eine
gute meinung von uns mit nach hause
nehmen
sie haben sich noch nicht um unseren
garten und feld bekümmert aber was sie
sind noch jung
sie müssten sich ein 10 20 jahre
wenigstens bei uns aufhalten
bis das sie lernten wo wir es allen
anderen nationen in der ganzen welt
zuvor getan ihn betrügen in der spitze
bereits nicht vom feld bau und sie alles
zu gestalten
ich baue zuerst mein herz denn um mich
herum alles zugestanden ihr wisst
erstaunlich viel aber er tut nichts
ich rede nicht von ihm sie sind der ba
kaster europäer den ich das bitte ich
mehr aus ich habe den ganzen tag ich
wollte sagen ihr wisst nichts
alles was ihr zusammengestoppelt bleibt
auf der oberfläche ihres verstandes wird
zulässt nicht zu empfinden
ihr kennt das wort nicht einmal was ihr
empfindung nennt ist schminke womit ihr
brutalität bestreicht ihr seid
wunderschöne masken mit lastern und
niederträchtig keiten ausgestoppt wie
ein fuchs bald mit herz und ein gemeinde
sucht man vergeblich die sind schon
zwölf jahre zu einem teufeln gegangen
im unglück dass man nicht alleine
mitteilt ist weniger eindeutig und
weniger bedrückend auf dem weg hierher
habe ich darüber nachgedacht
wenn ich einmal hinein gehe muss ich
gleich anfangen zu reden
daran war wollte wissen sie bescheid und
ich habe nichts mehr zu sagen wenn wir
zusammen bin sage ich ihm beispielsweise
nach lange umschweife man sie so
gefunden ihre hände werden gefaltet wir
reden aber nicht gescheitert sehen sie
unser könig redet man dann hören sie uns
zum untergewichten lande schlechte
nachricht ins auge zu sehen
es ist wichtig dass man ein bisschen
rechts im kreise der unglücklichen dass
mein sohn ist sich selbst überlässt bmw
ist im metallenen unbewusst und des
schmerzes noch die am wenigsten mit
delikten nehmen bewusst einen teil des
schmerzes
nicht
[Musik]
nach einem kurzen teilstück zu interieur
von maurice maeterlinck folgt jens todt
eine abrechnung mit der russischen
justiz und bürokratie und alexander
zucker wirkung gewinn ein stück welches
nach seiner erscheinung 1869 über 30
jahre verboten wurde
bis es auch geführt werden konnte
beschloss mir reicht's jetzt meine
vorgesetzten reißt mich in stücke wenn
die gläubiger nageln an meinem sagt ich
habe die misere sei also werde ich das
zeitliche segnen aber wie ein hund
therapieren will ich das hat noch lange
nicht
kommt gar nicht in frage eines
natürlichen todes sterben nie und nimmer
die natur und ihre gesetze das ist was
für idioten ich sterbe wie es mir passt
wo es mir passt und woran es mir passt
verstanden com tod wo ist dein stachel
du machst allen planen ein ende
also her mit dir und schluss mit den
schulden
schluss mit den rechnungen und schluss
mit der pumpe rhein lebt wohl
wir hören da oben und da unten ich bitte
um vergebung
meine herren vorgesetzten obwohl meine
freunde meine totengräber ihr folgen
hunde terrell thien ist nicht mehr
friede sein gebäuden oder oder brauchen
sie vielleicht auch einen verwalter ich
bin wirklich ein glänzender
geschäftsmann wenn sie sich überzeugen
wollen bitte hier sind meine zeugnisse
meiner erfahrung sind wirklich
außerordentlich vielschichtig ich bin
durch dick und dünn gegangen ganz zu
schweigen von einer unendlichen
redlichkeit meine herren das ist eine
einmalige gelegenheit
sie sind nicht interessiert
dann dann möchte ich sie aber bitten
sich zumindest meine adresse zu notieren
für den fall dass sie es sich noch
einmal überlegen ja bitte schreiben sie
oder wollen sie mich vielleicht auch
gleich ganz zu greifen
ich bin auch in finanzierung äußerst
versiert auf einen mann wie mich hat die
geschäftswelt keinerlei geheimnisse mit
einem wort ich biete ihnen produktivität
zuwachsraten gewinnchancen dass ihnen
der verstand stehenbleibt schlagen sie
diese hand nicht zurück schenken sie mir
ihr vertrauen ich sehe schon jetzt schon
sie denken sie können das auch ohne mich
da sind sie sich da sicher früher oder
später wird es ihnen leid tun
alleine können sie das doch gar nicht
hält sie brauchen einen fachmann sie
brauchen einen berater sie brauchen
einen vampir
[Musik]
iwan turgenjew ein monat auf dem lande
in diesem stück gibt es nur ein thema
die liebe
nirgendwo sonst findet man so viel
verzweiflung ihre dass jung sind als und
berechnung durch alle altersklassen
hindurch wird den möglichen mögliche
verbindung gesucht endlich sind wir
allein in antalya betroffen
sagen sie mir was mit ihnen los ist
nichts mit shell gar nichts
und wenn etwas wahr ist es vorbei das
kann doch jedem passieren oder auch über
den himmel ziehen wollten
wieso schauen sie mich so an
nur so ich bin glücklich öffnen sie das
fenster der garten ist so herrlich grüß
dich wind als hätte er nur auf die
gelegenheit gewartet herein zu wählen in
windeseile hat er das ganze zimmer
erobert jetzt lässt er sich nicht mehr
verjagen
sie sind jetzt so sanft und still wieder
abend nach einem gewitter nach einem
gewitter gab es denn ein gewitter
es hat sich nur zusammengebraut
tatsächlich wissen sie mich schnell ich
kann mir keinen menschen vorstellen
der gutmütige wäre als sie
lassen sie mich ausreden
sie sind tolerant liebenswürdig verlässt
sie verändern sich nicht
ich habe ihm viel zu verdanken
so soll der vertreter wieso sagen sie
dass ausgerechnet jetzt weiß ich nicht
ich bin fröhlich entspannt
lassen sie mich klappe sie sind ein
himmel
heute morgen hätten sie das nicht gesagt
hören sie michelle sie kennen mich
sie müssen mir verzeihen unser
verhältnis ist so rein so aufrichtig und
trotzdem nicht ganz natürlich ihr zwei
können nicht nur arkadi mann mann
sondern der ganzen welt offen in die
augen sehen ja aber genau das belastet
beschämt und ärgert mich und wie ein
kind will ich meinen ärger nem anderen
auslassen besonders gern an ihn hätte
ihnen dieses privileg nicht auf die
nerven
im gegenteil manchmal macht es spaß den
zug wählen den man liebt ja den man
liebt auch ich kann wie tatjana sagen
wozu noch das hat ja für trockene sie ja
ich liebe sie aber wissen sie raketen
was mir manchmal komisch vorkommt ich
liebe sie nur ist dieses gefühl so
abgeklärt so friedlich
es erregt mich nicht es wärmt mich aber
sie haben mich nie zum weinen gebracht
und es wäre zwingend notwendig glaub ich
was bedeutet das diese frage beantwortet
sich von selbst
wir kennen uns schon so lange vier jahre
ja wir sind alte freunde freunde
nein sie sind mehr für mich als ein
freund von thalia betroffene lassen
sieht dieses thema ich fürchte um mein
glück es könnte in ihren händen
zerbrechen nein nein nein
die krux ist sie sind zu gutmütig zu
tolerant mir gegenüber sie haben mich
verwöhnt seien sie nicht so gutmütig
werden ich höre ich weiß nicht wie sie
das sehen nicht persönlich wünsche mir
kein anderes glück viele würden nicht
beneiden nicht wahr
ich bin ihnen hilflos ausgeliefert
machen sie mit mir was sie wollen ich
kann ihnen jetzt nicht sehen will später
was ist das der anfang vom ende
wo das ende schlechthin
oder hätte er anfangen
[Musik]
ich hab dich einmal geküsst
ich habe mich zweimal gewinnt beim
briten habe ich gewusst wie ich hab ich
einmal gefragt
ich habe mich zweimal gefragt
doch ein prima hast du hier endlich ja
war die heilige johanna von george
bernard shaw aufgeführt 1923 wenn wenn
wenn wenn wenn das wörtchen wenn nicht
wär ging das kamel durchs nadelöhr
ich sage dir deine ganze kriegskunst ist
zwecklos weil dein ritter zu einem
ordentlichen schritt nichts taugen für
sie es krieg nur ein spiel
so wie tennis oder ihre anderen spiele
sie stellen regeln auf die dann sagen
was wer und was unfair ist die beladen
ihre armen pferde und sich selber mit
panzern um sich damit gegen pfeile zu
werden und dann fahren sie nun dann
können nicht mehr aufstehen und brauchen
ihre knappen damit ihnen auf geholfen
wird damit sie sich dann mit dem mann
der sie vom pferd geworfen hat um das
lösegeld streiten können verstehst du
nicht dass diese dinge vorüber und
veraltet sind hilft ein panzer gegen
schießpulver und selbst wenn glaubst du
wirklich dass die männer die für
frankreich und mit gott kämpfen pausen
machen und um lösegeld falschen seine
ritter die tun dass nämlich sie leben
davon
nein sie sollen kämpfen um zu siegen
sie sollen ihr leben in gottes hand
legen wenn sie in die schlacht ziehen so
wie ich das tue die einfachen leute die
verstehen dass die haben nämlich kein
geld um sich mit lösegeld zu
beschäftigen
aber halb nackt sind sie mir gefolgt
runter in den graben rauf auf die leiter
und über die mauer
für sie heißt es mein leben oder das
deine und gott schütze das recht ja
schütteln nur den kopf und der blaubach
soll ruhig sein 7 bad kreuzen und die
nase rümpfen über mich aber du du
erinner dich an die tat als deine ritter
und hauptleute sich weigerten mir zu
folgen als ich die engländer bei orion
angreifen wollte du hattest das duo
zugesperrt und mich in der stadt
festzuhalten aber dass statt volk und
die einfachen leute sind mir gefolgt sie
haben das tor gesprengt und gezeigt wie
man richtig kämpft wo sie hat ihr jetzt
alle wenn ich mich nach eurer wahrheit
gerichtet hätte keiner von euch hilft
mir keiner gibt mir ratschläge
ich bin allein
ich bin immer schon allein gewesen
mein vater mein vater der hat zu meinen
brüdern gesagt wirft sie doch ins wasser
wenn sie nicht hier bleiben will und
sich um einen lehrer kümmern
und da draußen da verblutet frankreich
ja
frankreich soll ruhig war blut
hauptsache mein lämmern geht's gut ich
dachte immer frankreich hätte freunde am
hofe des königs aber ich finde nur wölfe
die um stücke von seinem armen
zerrissenen leib kämpfen
ich dachte gott wäre überall und hätte
überall freunde weil er der freund aller
menschen ist und in meiner unschuld habe
ich geglaubt ihr würdet mich vor allem
beschützen wie türme gut
ich weiß jetzt bescheid ist immer gut zu
wissen woran man ist glauben nicht dass
sie mich schrecken könnt wenn ihr mir
sagt ich stehe allein frankreich steht
allein gott steht allein und was ist
meine einsamkeit im vergleich zu der
einsamkeit von gott zu der einsamkeit
von meinem land
ich sehe jetzt dass die einsamkeit
gottes meine stärke ist was wäre er wenn
er euren eifersüchtigen und kleinlichen
ratschlägen folgen wollte so soll auch
meine einsamkeit meine stärke sein
es ist besser mit gott allein zu sein
seine freundschaft lässt mich nicht im
stich nicht sein rad nicht seine liebe
im schutz seiner stärke willich warten
immer waren wagen waren wagen bis in die
tod ich gehe es zu den leuten raus ich
möchte da jetzt raus die liebe in ihren
augen wird mich über den hass in euren
augen hinwegtrösten
ihr werdet alle froh sein wenn ihr mich
brennend aber wenn ich ins feuer gehe
dann gehe ich durch das feuer in das
herz meines volkes hinein für die linie
zur zeit wohl ihr die wäsche auch
verbrennen casanova
nein die nehme ich mit es ist nicht viel
denn linie bowie auf reisen wohin und
wann jetzt gleich nicht nur in tux
gibt's totengräber sagt mein freund ihr
wollt ihr neues punsch mir wohl
versauern las dem stoos casanova braust
auf für euch erlaubt ist schluss für
mich ne schande schwerst ich würd rot
gelb seinen grund dass ich bis jetzt
kein die bin wer ich es nur ein dieb ist
könig bloß gnadenbrot empfängern
ihr seid bibliothekar casanova liste gut
freien lauf was soll's der
haushofmeister gießt mehr wasser in wein
das wisst ihr nicht mann trug erdbeeren
im sommer vor mir auf
und gab mir nichts das wisst ihr nicht
und das ein hahn der teufel hol ihn von
mitternacht bis 2 mit seinem falsett
lanzetten scharf das ohr durchbohrt mir
das wisst ihr nicht und das nicht ich es
war der kürzlich hoch geborenen gästen
im wappensaal die lanze wallensteins
seine reliquie zeigte blieb euch das
verborgen und wie man mir zum spott auf
zäune meine kleider fetzen gespießt hat
und verstümmelt all die seltenen
illustren pergamente und wie der
geistliche dies fed geschwür am leib der
welt umfassenden kirche drei wochen lang
nicht mit der heiligen schrift gemästet
ich würde mein pferd das fliegt man gibt
mir einen ackergaul die suppe ist so
heißt das sie die kehle mehr verbrennt
der graf will mich nicht grüßen
trotz der regel wonach der stärkere als
erster zu grüßen hat da ist eine gämse
im park verschwunden ich bin schuld
gesindel alles gleich halt lasst mich
reden erstmals hier in tux rettig wie
sie geprüfte versuch in voltaire sprache
ich zu bilden sie ein hohen gelächter
und trage ich eine stunde ausdrucksvoll
mit gesten tasso vor
gelächter werde ich wütend geht's noch
lauter zu neige ich den kopf zur rechten
schulter macht drei verbeugung spaß wie
sie marcel im jahre 47 die hoch geboren
lehrte nach beute ich mich zu schöner
damen hände kommt unterdrücktes prusten
müll ich mich in sie des menuetts
geheime reize einzuweihen drängt sich
der pöbel in der tür
und heute mai wollte scampi solist nicht
mehr mode
mir gehört gibt's augenzwinkern
verschlinge ich eilig einen pfirsich
lachen kann ich die nuss nicht knacken
lachen im knopfloch noch mehr lachen
veilchen ist schalt ich esse fasste
trinke wie nüchtern lachen ich singe los
sich ein lied wie auf bestellung lachen
und stoße in der hec den nachttopf um
ein lärm fröhlich ein krach als schlüge
man wem mit der axt 1 über sie lachen
bis schluckauf zieht welt
[Musik]
phoenix ein theater gedicht von marina
zwetajewa
[Musik]
automaten bücher von anna kleiner dieses
stück das man irgendwo zwischen
marieluise fleißer und öden von robert
ansiedeln kann wurde 1932 in hamburg
aufgeführt bevor 1933 meiners werk
verbot wurde
seitdem wurde es nie wieder in
deutschland gespielt
hallo hier ist das baden verboten lassen
sie mich sonst nicht lesen es ist
verboten in beiden tech zu baden nicht
einmal zum sterben kann man seine ruhe
haben
ach so sie wollten stift soll ich mich
jetzt vielleicht bei ihnen bedanken nein
das ist nicht nötig so und was soll ich
ihrer meinung nach jetzt anfangen ich
habe zwei abschiedsbriefe geschrieben
ich kann doch jetzt nicht wieder kommen
und sagen das ganze war ein irrtum
das kann nicht gut dass sie das einsehen
sagen sie mal warum sind sie eigentlich
noch einige glauben sie sie können mich
aus fragen weil sie sich in meine
angelegenheiten gemischt haben
bitte liebe ich meine es hat sich um
einen mann gehandelt den sie nicht
bekommen eben schon aber man bringt sich
doch nur aus der liebe um wenn man ihm
nicht bekannt es war nicht nur hässlich
und ich habe es mir so schön vorgestellt
warum haben sie mich rausgeholt dort hat
man wenigstens seine ruhe
sie sind doch noch so jung dass lieben
liegt noch vor ihm sozusagen sozusagen
es gibt auch menschen die nicht
gemeinsam und es gibt ideale für die
sich zu nehmen
jetzt bestellt sich meine tante schon
den trauer hat sie sind jetzt sozusagen
losgelöst vom früh
es gibt ja sie haben gar keine
verpflichtung gegen das was sie gestern
sie lassen den bräutigam mit dem
zylinder und vor der kirche stehen der
abend bot tisch ist gedeckt aber sie
setzen sich nicht mehr dazu sie sind
abgemeldet
und was wird jetzt aus mir
sie können doch nicht leugnen dass sie
gewisse verpflichtungen auf sich
genommen haben
sie werden ihr neues leben beginnen das
wird eine zeit kommen wo sie nicht
begreifen werden dass wir so
leichtsinnig mit ihrem leben um den
kunden muss doch gar nicht ihnen denn
sonst der allgemeinheit und sie werden
wieder lernen wie schön das leben ist
für einen menschen der seinen platz
ausfüllt so wunderschön wenn wir einmal
dankbar sein dass ich sie gegen
irgendwelchen gerettet haben
vielleicht hätte es einem wirklich
einmal leid wenn man tot ist und es
passiert irgendetwas wichtiges sehr
wichtiges wenn nichts besseres nachkommt
der fischteich der läuft ja nicht fort
sie werden nicht zurück wir sind in
automaten wurde frau adam ein grosser
kellerraum mit tischen und bänken links
gibt es einen glaskasten wir herrn der
wand entlang hinter den glasscheiben
präsentiert der vitrinenschrank
lachsschinken brötchen schlag
wurstbrötchen ja kurz brötchen salami
brötchen brötchen mit käse und viele
weitere sorten durch den einwurf einer
münze lässt sich eines der fächer öffnen
und der hungrige gast kann sich bedienen
neben dem büffel steht ein automatisches
klavier hat soeben leise und verstimmt
den schlager ich hab dich einmal geküsst
ich hab dich zweimal geküsst zu spielen
beginnt würstchen die herren mir
losziehen braucht keiner für den
weiteren mitgliedern
nein auch mein mann ist noch nicht
zurück ihr gern da wären wir wer ist
dass wir die maschine
ich habe dieses mädchen mitgebracht das
sehe ich aus dem wasser
das sehe ich ja wir sind ganz nass bei
sie hasst sie wird hier so wurden kann
ich mich eigentlich jetzt hinter dem
ofen wärmen
da ist sie können dann helfen die gäste
bedienen
du willst wohl so stehen bleiben bis man
auf dem boden kann fahren ich könnte
mich umziehen
du merkst der aale saada das buffet hier
ist von meiner mitgift gekauft von dem
geld das man seliger vater sich zusammen
gekratzt hat davon wird nichts vertan
da hinten steht ein eimer und einen
lappen mit dem können sie den boden
aufwischen dann spannen sie ihn über den
eimer damit er trocknet dann werden sie
sich eine schürze anziehen so können sie
nicht rumlaufen wenn alle kommen ein
eigenartiges mädchen und widerlich sieht
sie aus haben sie beinahe gesehen und
allerhand anderes kann man das fräulein
hinten rein zwicken oder muss man sich
erst vorstellen versuchen sie ist wenn
sie nicht so sehr beunruhigt
machen sie doch wisse sie können sagen
was sie wollen herr redakteur
aber was das volk beunruhigen kann
gehört nicht in einer zeitung sie
verwechseln würde unsere zeitung mit
ihrem schlafzimmer
solche sätze wie europa ist ein
pulverfass das jeden moment der zündende
funke fallen kann solche sätze sind
gesundheitsschädlich
schreiben sie ruhig gesagt ja es ist
auch nicht meine schuld dass die zeit
nicht ruhig sehen das ist noch immer wo
geschossen worden seit die welt besteht
und immer hat es vulkane gegeben die
ausgebrochen sind
lebenskunst jahren das ist die kunst
nicht dabei zu sein immer in dem zimmer
wenn es schießt nie in der nähe wenn der
vulkan ausbricht stimme war dann erst
später bekommen die herren vielen dank
wir warten nur kurz große regen
nachlässt das buffet ist kein
regenschirm wer nicht genießt muss eben
nass werden
[Musik]